Identify the x and
y-intercepts of the line
y is equal to 3x minus 9.
Then graph the line.
So the x-intercept,
I'll just abbreviate it
as x-int, that is where the
line intersects the x-axis.
So where it
intersects the x-axis.
Remember, this horizontal
axis is the x-axis.
So when something
intersects the x-axis,
what do we know
about its coordinate?
Its x-value could be anything,
but we know it's y-value is 0.
If we're intersecting,
if we're sitting
on the x-axis
someplace, that means
that we haven't moved
in the y-direction.
That means that y is 0.
So this means,
literally, that y is 0.
So we need to find
the x-value defined
by this relationship
when y is equal to 0.
Similarly, when we talk
about the y-intercept,
I'll do it down
here-- when we talk
about the y-intercept,
what does that mean?
Well, y-intercept
means-- so this
is the y-axis right over
here running up and down.
The y-intercept is
the point at which
the line intercepts the y-axis.
So what's going on?
If we're at the
y-axis, our y-value
could be anything depending on
where we intersect the y-axis.
But we know that we haven't
moved to the right or the left.
We know that our x-value
is 0 at the y-intercept.
So over here, our
x-value is going to be 0.
And to find the
actual point, we just
have to find the
corresponding y-value defined
by this relationship
or this equation.
So let's do the first one first.
The x-intercept is
when y is equal to 0.
So we set y is equal to 0,
and then we'll solve for x.
So we get 0 is
equal to 3x minus 9.
We can add 9 to both
sides of this equation
to isolate the x-term.
So we get 9 is equal to 3x.
These cancel out.
We could divide both sides by 3.
Divide both sides by 3.
We get 3 is equal to
x or x is equal to 3.
So the point y is equal to 0, x
is equal to 3 is on this line.
And let me put it in order.
x-coordinate always goes first.
So it's 3 comma 0.
So this is the origin.
1, 2, 3 is right over here.
That is 3 comma 0.
This right here is
the x-intercept.
And remember, notice that
point lies on the x-axis,
but the y-value is 0.
We haven't moved up or down.
When you think
x-intercept, you say, OK,
that means my y-value is 0.
So I have to solve
for the x-value.
Now we do the opposite
for the y-intercept.
And the y-intercept, we're
sitting on this line,
x-value must be 0.
So let's figure out what y is
equal to when x is equal to 0.
So y is equal to-- I want
to do it in that pink color.
y is equal to-- y is equal
to 3 times-- x is 0 now.
3 times 0 minus 9.
Well, 3 times 0 is just 0.
So 0 minus 9.
Well that's, just
equal to negative 9.
So we have the point
0 comma negative 9.
So when x is 0, we
go down 9 for y.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
So right there is the
point 0 comma negative 9.
Notice, it sits on the y-axis.
That's why it's the y-intercept.
And the x-value is 0.
We haven't moved to
the left or right.
All you need is two
points for a line,
so we're now ready to graph.
We essentially just have
to connect the dots.
So it's going to look
something like this.
It's going to look
something-- our line.
I don't have a good
line tool, so I'm
going to try my best
to draw it nicely--
is going to look
something like that.
And you just keep going.
You just keep going.
You want to do a straight line.
So it just keeps going on
and on and on like that.
It just keeps going.
And I could keep going all
the way in that direction,
and then-- but then my line
doesn't look as straight all
of a sudden.
I think you get
the general idea.
I can keep going like that,
and then keep going like that.
I don't have a nice
ruler to do it with.
And we're done.